complete concentration gnomish care is
rehearsing one of the most important
concerts of her career to date her first
performance in Berlin she has traveled
here especially from her home in
Budapest Allah Azza from wanna when I
play here i am representing Syria abroad
that's a big honor for me when I
sterzick cuddle a pre-concert dinner
with other Syrian musicians living in
Europe the orchestra brought them
together after years away from home in
the studio knows of my alma there are
some Obama this expert orchestra is a
chance for us to come together again at
the same time it's an opportunity to
show a different side of Syria not the
pictures of war and destruction that
everyone is used to seeing I learn he is
sort of horrible with them are just
before the big performance and despite
the heat thousands have come to listen
it was thanks to this performance that I
could come to Germany it's a rare
opportunity to see people i love who
mean a lot to me and now the concert
10 compositions from classical to jazz
the season-opening of the world renowned
Berlin Philharmonic played by the syrian
expat Philemon accor costura
you